colle Steve Evans as you know Steve is a
renowned probabilist and one of many
things that he works on is population
genetics so he will turn things upside
down and tell us about the fortime view
of
evolution okay uh thanks very much you
so um so unfortunately I get to do the
the stuff that isn't very visually
appealing right the forwards in Time
stuff there's not trees and uh things
like that you know it sort of looks much
more kind of analytic rather than than
combinatorial
but um so you
know I guess I sort of really don't need
to um explain why we're um interested in
these sort of questions that shishi and
Anand have already um you know talked
about uh the the the kinds of uh issues
that we're uh concerned with here um and
uh you know detecting um when uh
selection has been present uh inference
about historical mutation rates you know
uh things about past population sizes
whether there's you the migrations ad
mixture um that sort of thing okay
and you said you're going to do forward
in time I mean I would think that that
would say that
questions about the future in some sense
no forwards in time means you know in a
sense describing rather than describing
how you know uh
genealogies sort of uh evolve going
backwards in time it's sort of you know
if you start at some time in the past
with a given genetic composition of your
population how that will evolve forwards
in time but I could also start at the
present right yes I could start at the
present and predict things of course yes
I that's interesting question yeah no
yeah I mean it's of course exactly the
the the same uh thing yes right sort of
prediction rather than kind of inference
no
certainly and so you know in order to to
do this kind of statistical inference
you know we sort of need to have some
idea of the um Dynamics um by which the
the genetic de uh genetic composition of
a population will change with time when
there's things like selection or um ad
mixture or um population size change
occurring and so you know we we we need
some models
here and so um you know this is you know
this is kind of looking like the the you
know FBI boiler plate that you sort of
see at the start of every you know DVD
you know know sort of so you've sort of
seen uh you know two versions of this
already and um so you know this is just
a kind of yet again an explanation of
where the the simplest type of uh right
Fisher model uh appears um except um
here um uh to start with at least I'll
be particularly looking at the case um
where um uh
uh each individual which is you know
individuals uh um you know genes you
know each gene is either of type big a
or or little a and uh then you know
there's just this idea that uh we have
reproduction happening in discrete
non-overlapping Generations each
individual um produces some very large
number of germ cells
um of its own type we're not having
mutation here at the moment and um then
you know there's this sort of harvesting
of or sampling of um uh the the the end
cells from this sort of huge pool um
that produces um the the the next um
generation and um so you know the way
that we're going forwards in time now
from generation little end to generation
little n+ one um you know there's the
the formation of this this gamut pool
and then the the sampling of big n um uh
individuals from this this massive gamut
pool and then there's this uh sort of
little bit of slide of hand that people
you know sometimes um find a little bit
confusing that out of this story um you
know comes this uh mechanism that's most
easily described in terms of the idea of
you know individuals picking you know
parents um uniformly at random you know
each individual um picks a a parent um
at random from the the the previous
generation with um each parent being
equally likely and you know here the
we're um marking the types you know the
two types big a and little a in solid
circles and um uh Open Circles just to
indicate you know sort of what's going
um on there and you know just uh you
know of course you know in reality um we
have a a picture that's like this one
here and then you know we can just
disentangle it to make something that
looks a little bit
clearer okay and you know here uh what's
um going on is uh uh you know we um sort
of start um at at Time Zero uh with a
population um that has eight individuals
um uh three of them uh of the solid
Circle type uh five of the open circle
type and then as time evolves um
eventually uh we proceed to um having
fixation uh where everybody is of the
open um Circle type okay in this
particular realization of the
story okay and so you know what we have
here is just a very simple um at least
conceptually very simple um discrete
time Mark of chain um that has uh you
know where we keep track of the number
of type A individuals obviously that's
all we need to keep track of because we
get the number of type little a
individuals just by
subtraction and so we have this discrete
time Markov chain that I'll call um ZN
that has State space zero up to n and
then uh the the one-step transition
probabilities well they're just going to
be given um by a binomial distribution
right so we have a binomial distribution
where we've got capital N trials and if
we think of getting a a type big a
individual um as a success uh the
probability of a success is you know the
current number of type A individuals um
divided by Big N right and so that's
what's um going on here in in this
formula here right so
um this is obviously something that you
know when n's not big n's not too large
is very easy to simulate and also um of
course if we want to look at multi-step
transition probabilities for a Markov
chain like this um we just have to take
uh this Matrix PJ and raise it to a
power and you know when big end's not
very large that's not hard to do but you
know if big ends on the order of
thousands tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands and you know we want to raise
this Matrix to a very high power again
on the the sort of order of the
population size um which is sort of the
the the the relevant um number of of
steps here where you'll see significant
changes in the the the the population
composition you know that starts to get
to be a a numerically rather unpleasant
thing to
do
okay okay so you know just um to you I
mean I've already said uh many of these
things but if you know we're interested
in a a multi-step transition probability
like this that we go from having I type
a big a individuals to J big a type
individuals in um K Generations then you
know that Matrix with those binomial
probabilities in it we've got to raise
um to the K power and uh you know the K
where inter the scale of K on which
interesting things happen is of the
order of big n okay so of course you
want to um take a big Power of a matrix
you'd like to to to diagonalize it and
it's not that hard to show that the the
I values of this transition Matrix P are
um these um numbers here right obviously
one's an igen value like it is for any
stochastic Matrix and then like this but
then you sort of see
that you know the the second IG value
was 1 - 1 / n and so that gives you an
indication that you know you have to
look at things on the order of end
Generations um in order to see some
significant action um but
unfortunately there's no knowing formula
for the igen vectors and if you ever
hear Warren Yuan talking about this he
just you know sort of says something
like you know all you young people out
there don't try to solve this problem
right you know there isn't an answer and
nobody will care even if you you do you
know is basically so
um you know so what we'd like to do is
you know have some sort of approximation
for what goes on when Big N is is
large so you know what we have is that
um conditional on there being um you
know ZN uh type A type big a individuals
around um ZN +1 the number of type A
individuals at time little n + one is of
course um just a you know because we had
this binomial story it's a a sum of Bol
random variables random variables that
can just take the values zero and one
and conditionally these guys are
independent and identically distributed
with you know this is the success
probability and this is the the the
failure probability okay so you know if
you go back to your sort of Elementary
probability course um you know from this
that conditional on ZN the expected
value of this change in the number of
big a individuals has expected value
zero and this this variance here right
just sort of standard formula for the
the mean and variance of a of a binomial
distribution okay but now we've got a
binomial with a really large um number
of uh
trials and uh so you know we're adding
up a lot of benly random variables and
so you know we can be a little handwavy
and heuristic and say um this difference
in the the number of big a individuals
given um the current
number is something that in distribution
should be close to a a normal
distribution with you know mean and
variance given by the the mean and
variance that we figured out here right
so that's sort of what you'd believe
from the the the central limit theorem
that you know conditionally this is what
the the distribution of this increment
um should should look
like I can do this kind of okay
so now a nicer thing to look at um is uh
to divide by in and look at the popula
uh the proportion of the population
that's type big a right because now you
know previously we had a state space 012
all the way up to Big N um now we're
sort of putting things on a you know a
common state space basically the
interval 0 to
1 and so we're just dividing by um big
again and so we know that you know you
rescale a gassian random variable by a
constant you get another gassian random
variable back and we're just rescaling
by by Big N here and so
heuristically the the change in the
proportions given the current proportion
um will be you know normal or gaussian
with expected value zero and this as its
uh variant variance okay okay and so
another way of saying that is that this
um change in proportion given the
current proportion looks like this guy
here right the square root of the
variance times just a a standard normal
random variable right and random normal
random variable with mean zero and and
variance um sorry um not not a standard
normal random variable sorry a normal
random variable with mean um zero and
variance 1 / n okay because we've got
the the the 1 /n up here
right okay
so modulo this um sort of factor out the
front here we're sort of dealing with um
sort of
increments that um you know are looking
like they've got mean zero and variance
1 / n and they're got a gas in
distribution and and you know that's
reminiscent of an extremely well-studied
uh stochastic process namely Branan
motion so let me sort of hopefully be
reminding most of you what standard
Branan motion is or um introducing you
to it um at the very least so you know
standard Branan motion now is a
continuous time stochastic process so
you know time here is continuous rather
than discret
and we've got this real valued guy and
it starts off at zero and then if we
look at successive increments of this
thing um what you know non-overlapping
increments what we get are independent
random
variables that have mean
zero they have variance that's equal to
the the length of the interval that
we're incrementing
over and um those increments are are
normally distributed right and so in
particular if we um increment over an
interval that's of length 1 / n what we
see is a normal random variable with
mean zero and um variance 1/n right
which you know is exactly the sort of
thing um that appeared here and so um
here you know approximately what we've
got is something that looks like an of
Branan motion that's just being rescaled
by this factor that depends on the the
current um proportions of type big a in
the
population and so what this suggests is
if we look at the the the population um
proportions and then speed up time by uh
a factor of big n right where big n's
the the population size um then you know
in terms of the the number of type big a
individuals we're doing this then you
know we should be sort of converging off
to some stochastic process that's
evolving in continuous time that um you
know if you don't know sort of formally
what this sort of expression means it
sort of looks right it sort of says that
you know the limit you know kind of a
little increment in the limit process
should look like you know a little
increment in the the Branan motion
multiplied by a factor that looks like
this right and that's um you know
following on from uh you know the the
the discussion that we had before that
you know went back to the central limit
theorem and so um you know somewhat more
formally um we just sort of integrate
both sides and and you know this can be
all made rigorous well to start with you
know just what this expression means um
you know this is a a so-called Ito
integral and so you just need um to
understand a little stochastic calculus
and then the sense in which the
convergence occurs is just you know very
well understood um you know convergence
and distribution of stochastic processes
and so this object here um is what's
usually called the neutral right Fisher
diffusion okay diffusion is just you
know probability jargon for um a a
stochastic process that takes values in
the real numbers or more generally idian
space that moves around continuously
doesn't have jumps that's what sort of
diffusion means to to a
probabilist okay
and so you know well what does that sort
of get
us okay
well we can just use the sort of you
know the most Elementary stochastic
calculus which is you know goes by the
name of idos Lama that says you know if
f is suitably smooth then we have
something that um looks like this now
you know if you've never seen this sort
of thing before it's sort of a bit
disturbing because you know if you just
used the Newtonian calculus and um you
know which is you know and tailor series
you know integration by parts change of
variable right they're all um the same
thing really um then you just
expect that F of XT would look like this
but then there's this funny thing on the
end here um and that has to do with you
know the paths of Branan motion are
sufficiently rough um that you sort of
have to go to the second term in well
you know the the quadratic term in in
the tailor expansion um in order to sort
of get a a legitimate integration by
parts formula and so that's what's going
on here and um but you know this can all
be it's really just a a tailor series
type um
argument and so if we take expected
values of both sides here so we're
interested in the expected value of some
function of the the proportion at time t
of type big a individuals given that we
started with um little X proportion of
type big a individuals then that
function um will solve this this partial
differential equation all I've done here
is take expected value of both sides and
remember the expected value of my little
increments of brownan motion they're
zero right and so this doesn't this is
bit this doesn't contribute anything to
the expected values so when I take
expected values I just get you know this
stuff and this and then you know I
differ and check both sides with respect
to T and it all pops out so just as a
sort of an example of that suppose I'm
interested in this quantity here right
which is um you know I pick two
individuals at random from the
population what's the probability that
they'll have different alic types you
know that one will be big a and the
other will be little a or vice VI Versa
then just using this partial
differential
equation um you know you end up seeing
that the expected value of this guy um
you know does does this and we just
recognize the usual differential
equation for the the exponential
function and so we see that this guy
here which is you know the um the
heterozygosity um sort of declines um
exponentially right and you know that
should ring bells because it's you know
just um exactly mirroring what happens
you know with going on in the coalescent
that um you know you're having the the
time uh that it takes for sort of two
individuals to to find a common ancestor
um has an exponential distribution and
so this exactly mirrors that sort of
backwards in time thing from the the uh
the coal
okay
so
um it's sort of not hard to see um in
this model that you know if you let it
evolve I always got to be careful here
probabilist talk about you know
stochastic processes evolving right and
that has you know in a sense nothing to
do with you know natural selection that
meaning of evolution right it's sort of
um you know the way physicists would
talk about a dynamical system evolving
so you just let this thing run for long
enough and eventually everybody's going
to be of the same type they'll all be of
type little a or of type big a and so
that means that you know these uh
limiting um proportions you're either um
everybody's of type little a or
everybody's of type big a and so the
first thing to figure out is you know
what's the probability that you've
you've fixed in state um zero you know
everybody's of type little a by time T
that when you started out with the
proportion of Big A's being X and you
have similarly the the probability that
you fix with everybody being of type big
a now both of these guys solve exactly
the same partial differential equation
in terms of what's going on with the
derivatives that's just coming from what
we figured out um on the previous slide
but of course what changes here is the
boundary conditions right and you know
you sort of have obvious um uh boundary
conditions and um one thing that's easy
to show uh is that um you know the
probability that um you fix in
zero um uh eventually which is just
letting T go to Infinity in this is 1
minus X so in other words the probab
that you end up with everyone being type
little a is equal to the proportion of
type little A's that you began with and
similarly the probability that you end
up with everyone being of type big a is
the proportion of type bigas that you
began with right and that doesn't
actually need um a you know all the
stochastic calculus it's just a fact
that you're dealing with a a marting
gale for you know a fair game for people
who know that
jargon okay now one thing that sort of
possible to show um is that you know
this sort of thing that we're interested
in um you know the expected value of
some function of the current proportion
of big a given that we started off with
proportion Little X well you know you
sort of have a chunk of mass um at zero
a chunk of mass at one and then you have
the situation that's described in you
know how the mass is distributed um when
you haven't fixed and so this thing here
you know usually called the transition
probability um again it's going to solve
our um basic um pte if we look at the
behavior in the the variable that's
taking account of where we started and
fix the variable that's taking account
of where we end and if we want to know
how this thing behaves in terms of the
variable that's taking account of where
we end up well you just have to work
with this do a little integration by
parts and um you you end up with a
slightly different PD um for for that
function where Little X is fixed and Y
is now the the the variable where all
the actions
happening okay so you know we've got all
these partial differential equations you
know well you know how do we solve them
so life would be great if you know the
answer was you know log of s of X or
something like that right but
unfortunately um it's it's not um but
it's sort of almost as good as that
right that
um you know remember with the original
right Fisher guys we wanted to
diagonalize this big transition Matrix
and Warren Yuans tells us that we
shouldn't do that that right that the
you there aren't analytic expressions
for the igen vectors the great thing
here is that you know you pass to this
limit and you're dealing with ion
functions instead of igon vectors and
you know here um there are analytic
Expressions um for what these things are
and okay it sort of looks um uh kind of
of
nasty um but uh you know the these
functions that appear here you know
they're things that you know Mathematica
and maple know about right they're not
sort of off in some exotic Nether world
and also you see here that uh you know
we've got this infinite sum but you know
when T's are tall large um this uh
exponential is going to be sort of
killing um all but the the the first few
terms and so you know numerically this
is not that bad to to deal
with and so you know what we see is that
the um the the right Fisher um chain and
the the diffusion approximation kind of
handles you know what happens when Big N
the population size um goes off to uh uh
infinity and we don't have um all the um
things that might be going on you know
sort of selection uh you know population
structure um you know population growth
that sort of thing um but you know in
principle the same ideas um uh apply to
handle um many of those you know kind of
uh extra uh features that you might want
to
include and so you know the the simplest
one to to talk about and the one that
I'll talk about first is what happens if
populations size varies so I've used
slightly different notation to what
Anand had he had you know eer for this
sort of factor that was describing um uh
you know uh a varying population size
and of course for him time was going
backwards whereas for me time's going uh
forward but there's still this um thing
that you know he observed that when you
look at it from the coalescent point of
view um all your doing is you know
speeding up or slowing down the the the
coalesence rates um here it's exactly um
the the same story that the the the
relevant um stochastic differential
equation for the diffusion approximation
looks just like the one we had before
except that there's you know we're
dividing by the square root of the the
relative population size and you know
one way of interpreting this is that we
have the the same model it's just that
you know time is getting sort of sped up
and slowed down um according to the the
population size increasing the
population size slows down the speed
with which um the um the population
proportion of type A alals changes you
know just as um unarmed uh observed you
know from the the coalescent point of
view okay what about if we have um
a Sit situation with
mutation where you know here we've just
got two types and so we've got Big A's
mutating into little A's and little A's
mutating into um Big A's and so um you
know we assume that Big A's mutate into
little A's um uh with uh a per
generation probability like this and you
know similarly for little a is mutating
Into The Big A's well you know you can
just go through exactly the same
analysis as we did um before and see you
know the the
change um in uh numbers of type A
individuals um the expected value of
that condition on the current number of
big a individuals um is given by an
expression like this and then you know
if we divide by begin to look at
proportions um we get something like
this and the great thing is that we have
a 1 over n here so that you know the the
sort of story that led to us having this
kind of nice continuous limit as we did
before holds and this is the the
stochastic differential equation that we
end up with so the the thing that's got
to do with um the the brownan motion is
exactly the same and then we have a sort
of DT ter term here right so we've got
this if you like sort of um bias term or
um uh yeah I mean that's probably the
best way to put it sort of a a biased
term um that you know is kind of uh
handling um the the um uh you know the
effect of the the mutation and of course
if you took expected values of both
sides here um you would just get an
ordinary differential equation for the
um expected
um proportion that you know would be um
you know exactly the the sort of one
that you'd
expect okay and um of course you know
one thing that goes on in in this
situation is that you can have um uh
convergence off to some sort of
stationary regime uh where you have you
know some Big A's and some little A's
around um you know you don't have to go
off to
uh um uh fixation anymore in in this
situation
okay selection sort of a little bit more
um
complicated
so um the idea here now is that remember
in the past ZN + one given ZN um was
conditionally binomially distributed
with um capital n
trials and this is the um success
probability and so what you do is just
um make the success probability now
proportional to this and so if Alpha is
bigger than zero then type A's have a
selective Advantage if Alpha's smaller
than zero little A's have a selective
advantage and then um the you know the
failure probability you keep it what it
was before four and then um you know you
just have to do some messing around with
um well just expanding out geometric
series or um uh you know kind of a
little bit of tailor series type stuff
and what you see is when you look at the
level of proportions that the expected
change in proportions in one generation
is given by this and the great thing is
again we have this 1 over n Factor um
and then the the errors in this
approximation you know uh Big O of 1
over n squ so they um don't hurt us and
so the resulting stochastic differential
equation that you get um you know has
the same term uh in the front of the the
Branan increment and then again you have
this so-called drift term this sort of
uh you know bias um that uh enters in uh
this way
and here there's sort of something um
you know where uh sort of the hloy
working with the haid story does kind of
make a difference if we you know
actually sort of assign Fitness to
mating pairs um then you know we'd get
um something that was a little bit more
complicated than this um quadratic uh
thing here and so um but you know since
I've have chosen not to sort of talk
about the diploid story um let's you
know uh we'll we'll gloss over
that okay
so Anand um you know sort of talked
about you know kind of a general story
where you've got um uh a whole bunch of
deems and you know the deems are of
different sizes and you have you know
mutation
probabilities um between each pair of
deems um one can do exactly the same
thing here but just for Simplicity I'll
just suppose that I've got two
populations um that are of the the the
same
size and
uh then uh the the sort of stochastic
differential equation that you end up
with um not surprisingly and there
should be DT terms both there sorry the
sort of you know
uh is this kind of thing here and again
if you take expected values you'll just
get ordinary differential equations that
you know look right right that it's just
um you know you've got stuff going from
uh you know the prime population to the
double Prime population at rate beta and
vice versa okay so you know let's get
there should be a DT there and a
DT um term there okay and so you know
one can ramp this up to um uh you know a
whole bunch of deems and even try to
sort of move to a story where you have
continuous um geography right so rather
than just you
know of population sort of connected by
um migration you know you sort of have
population um you know that sort of just
spread out over a continuous geography
and you know things become considerably
harder and kind of technically a lot
more interesting in that
situation um similarly you know one can
have um more than two types um I sort of
haven't really gone into the the the
details here um you know when you had
two types everything was about you know
binomials when you have more than two
types everything's going to be about
multinomial probability distributions
but you know the central the limmit
theorem will work for them just as it
worked for binomial probability
distributions and so um you know the
whole argument will um uh go through uh
and you know I just sort of haven't kind
of bothered to to to work through the
the details there because um you know
it's sort of actually writing things as
as sdes in that case is not really um
all that Illuminating sort of in the the
the probabilistic jargon it's better to
think of these things as Solutions of a
so-called Martingale problem um where um
you know you don't sort of kind of in a
sense coordinati everything with Branan
motions it's sort of like doing
differential geometry where you know
once you start doing sort of hard
differential geometry writing everything
in coordinates is not necessarily the
best way way to
go okay so let me just finish up so you
know obviously I've just sort of
scratched the the the surface here um
and you know one thing that I didn't
talk about although I sort of hinted at
um was the the connection between this
diffusion um uh forwards in time
approach or it's sometimes called the
the perspective approach um and things
like the coal that looked backwards in
time and um for a long time there was
sort of like formal mathematical
connections between these things you
know I sort of showed that if you were
looking at this um you know expected
heterozygosity that that was something
that you looked reminiscent of things
that you saw in the the coalescent and
in general kind of higher moment type
things for the neutral right Fisher um
you know were representable in things
that look reminiscent of the coalescent
but then sort of due to the work of um
you know particularly people like Peter
Donnelly and um Tom CTS you know there's
a you know Wonderful sort of theory now
um that sort of really explains all of
that stuff um you know from a way that
in a way that doesn't make it look just
like an analytic curiosity but you know
really merges both the the forwards in
time and backwards in time approaches um
I haven't talked about what goes on with
multiple Loi and
recombination you know essentially you
know that's something that can be also
talked about um in terms of the sort of
diffusion models um you just basically
have a Branan motion for each Locus and
those Branan motions um you know don't
evolve independently there's some uh uh
Cor coration between them due to the
fact that um you know you have um the
the sort of correlation that um Anan
spoke about with um you know uh
recombination rates and certainly
something that you know I haven't talked
about here is well you know the sort of
some of the the you know the simplest
pde the neutral right Fisher one um you
know that's something that we can talk
about in terms of igen values and um
igen
functions uh but when you start even
sort of introducing
selection uh that's sort of something
where there's not kind of uh you know
you you're not just sort of using sort
of
well-known um special functions and uh
things get harder there and you know in
other circumstances say you know if uh
the population size is varying and
things like that uh you basically um
seem to need to do something like um
solve the pte um numerically or you know
there's things along those lines and
also uh for certain basian things you
know you'd want to simulate the the
stochastic differential equation so you
know I haven't talked about all of the
um very interesting and important sort
of numerical problems
and also um you know haven't talked
about how the the the kind of outputs of
these models which are you know
essentially you
know what they're giving you is kind of
you know one point on the likelihood you
know how that's going to be input into
statistical inference right you know cuz
if you're doing maximum likelihood you
know you sort of want to maximize over a
whole likelihood
surface and so you're going to be need
to be you know Computing something um
for one of these models over and over
again and similarly if you're wanting to
do something um basian and so uh doing
these sort of numerical calculations uh
efficiently is certainly something
that's um uh very important okay so I'll
leave it
there any questions for
uh she she talked about some uh other
kinds of coalesence and she said that
they kind of if the standard one
corresponds to this the others
correspond to other kinds of Levy
processes is there much done on that
board not anywhere near as much um but
there's a um famous uh or inFAMOUS seven
author paper um that basically figures
um that that out um and the authors
eidge will'll be visiting here
blot
um uh
Ving uh BNA I've got four
anyone who sorry schin yeah schweinsburg
um two more right it is seven auth I
believe right yeah yeah and um yeah so
the thing that happens there is as you
sort of say the the role of brown and
motion is going to then be played by
sort of something like a a Ley process
is the the the essential sort of idea
and you're getting something with jumps
because um you know the way that these
guys are are produced um the way that
you get out of the the um Kingman
coalescent world or the vanilla flavored
right Fisher world is where
um you know you have individuals that
you know rarely have extremely large
numbers of Offspring and so the way that
that shows up in the forwards in time
model is jumps and the way that it shows
up in the um uh backwards in time model
is multiple coalesence or even multiple
simultanous coalescence so at the same
time you have you know 15 guys all
merged here and 23 guys all merge over
here right that's so you have all of
that stuff so I mean just that um you
you need you need individuals to have
lots of Offspring on on on short time
scales on the coalescent on the rescaled
time you know it can be no everyone
could have a very tight distribution of
Offspring on the actual single
generation time as long as there's like
time correl correlations over time oh
yeah so that's of
course I don't know that that that that
would sort of involve
um you're not just having sort of a
Marian model from generation to
generation right yeah but there
um well there though I mean if you're
sort of moving a way to people having
large numbers of
Offspring um because of selection right
then you'll get into yet another class
of models which is that instead of
having this story where um you know
basically you've got things moving
around in a Brownian way um what you end
up with is sort of a deterministic
trajectory with um gussian noise around
it I mean in a sense it's you know a
sort of a more
boring um model but you know if you have
really strong selection then you know if
it's advantageous you know you're just
going to zoom off to
fixation and then sort of around that
trajectory um what you have it's sort of
like if you it's more like a a classical
Central limit thing if you sort of like
subtract off that deterministic
trajectory then what's left over is um
just a given by a a gaussian stochastic
process whose covariant structure has to
do with the the the trajectory and so
there's really not a lot of um uh
uh you know sort of papers in that area
it's um guy called Norman from the early
'70s wrote a couple of papers about it
and then sort of no one ever seems to
have actually sort of followed up on it
and uh you know cuz this sort of story
here I mean John wakeley has a a really
nice article about you know as you sort
of noticed everything here um sort of
depended on this rather delicate kind of
of assumption that um you know
the sort of selection was rescaling like
one over n you know mutation was
rescaling like you know and so you get
this really lovely Theory but you know I
guess John wakley's metaphor you know is
like the the the drunk looking for his
keys um you know under the street light
because you know that's the light's
better there it's not where he lost his
keys and so you know he you know in that
article kind of questions the relevance
of a lot of this Theory to to to many
population genetics problems just
because you know is it really the case
that you know you're in a world that of
course you know obviously you haven't
passed to a limit but you know you
you're working with you know
some
specific population size that's finite
some specific you know fitnesses etc etc
you know are you really in a world where
this limiting story has relevance and so
you know that's it's always a good
question to ask that
you okay
thanks